(laughter)
(upbeat dance music)
- Nobody likes you, you girl.
- Well, you're a different
color than me, and that's bad.
- Oh, yeah?
Well, you dress like a--
- Now, hold on a second.
- [Kids] Whoa, Mr. T!
- Never make fun of
the way a man dresses.
The way a man dresses
is his business.
Remember that,
whether it's overalls,
chains, or feather earrings,
however they dress, it's
not to be joked about.
I pity the fool that judges
another man's clothing.
- I'm sorry I judged
your clothing.
- It's okay.
(upbeat rock music)
- Hey Scout, there's
a man over there
who said he'll give us
candy if we get in his van.
- Oh, I don't know if
that's a good idea, Timmy.
- (sighs) What
are you afraid of?
Is it because you have a
stupid name, like Scout?
- Hey!
- [Kids] Whoa, Mr. T again!
- Never make fun
of a person's name.
Your mama gave you that name,
or you made it up for
business purposes.
Either way, it's personal.
I pity the fool that make
fun of another man's name.
Mr. T's a cool name.
It's a cool name, Mr. T.
(upbeat rock music)
- Hey Scout, wanna
do some drugs?
- Aren't drugs bad?
- I don't know.
If you're afraid of drugs,
we could drink a
bunch of alcohol.
- Yum, that sounds good.
- Well, guess what?
Your hair is stupid.
- Never make fun--
- Oh!
- Of another person's hair.
- [Kids] Hey, Mr. T.
- A person's hair is the artwork
that they present
to the heavens.
It's just like I've been saying.
(upbeat dance music)
♪ Hair ♪
♪ It isn't fair ♪
♪ Beware ♪
♪ People care about their hair ♪
♪ H is for the home
where I lay my head ♪
♪ And I cry about your
mean jokes in my bed ♪
♪ A is for anxiety
that fools provoke ♪
♪ When they looking at my hair ♪
♪ And they making jokes ♪
♪ I is for I don't
like the way I feel ♪
♪ When you're joking that
my haircut does not appeal ♪
♪ R is for the real
mean jokes you make ♪
♪ And the hurtful little
pot shots that you take ♪
And for your information,
it's not even a haircut.
It's a rare form of
male pattern baldness.
You fools.
(crying)
For real.
(upbeat rock music)
- I do what I.